welcome to this video the rematch just
for the game we just had in this viewer
channel charm I'm a bit short on time
here due to an upcoming appointment so I
didn't do any big recap of the game the
first game that we played you really
played a good a good tough game and I
want to give him this rematch so this
will also be a bit short on analysis
just just the game basically okay let's
see um it's a groom for type of position
where he didn't manage to take on c3m
this should be quite comfortable for
wide 22 maybe yeah mmm I can't have can
try for for a quick quick attack here
with h4 g4 and stuff maybe come on and
I'm in the mood to to do something to do
something a bit too risky maybe lie so
g4 here yeah come on if I've I'm just
taking and it's not really really on
maybe if I've takes Queenie said man I
could go to 26 as well and so just push
em yeah it's not a clear-cut attack
maybe e5 Bishop d3 and h5 this is a way
to to get things going the the more
brutal way is h5 g5 and sacrifice on g 5
i'm not sure though that this is really
working I I doubt it to be honest ok so
II five is playing c5 probably but after
the capture Bishop takes I keep my
center yeah as I should do that c5 so
what am i doing against at c5 just age
50 Bishop d3 h5 he plays g5 with that
one now thats this I didn't expect just
take it on yeah let's just take it now
here to threaten h5 and you cannot move
the King because h6 is hanging some age
50 yeah ok
I'm threatening to take and take on age
six and this looks pretty pretty
dangerous to say the least okay my take
here first like I take him okay the
thing is I'm wondering maybe I should
take on age six first yeah that's that's
cleaner I guess Bishop takes hd6 check
and there's nothing hanging on f3 if I
would have captured first in g6 yeah
okay take now and that's night g 5 l
also ok Jack let's let's do that first
then now see takes Bishop takes Queen h6
are really hmm Mac come on that's that's
that's a simple way and probably
probably am pretty clean just last
resign just winning this winning this
bishop yeah as mentioned I'm a bit in
early so challenge I can only play two
games I'm sorry because I need to go
yeah well i hope you enjoyed those two
games thanks for watching